Herkese merhaba Eee Öncelikle Böylesine
güzel bir günde böyle güzel bir salonda
ve sizler gibi muhteşem bir seyircinin
önünde Özellikle de büyüdüğüm şehirde
olmak benim için çok gurur verici O
yüzden çok teşekkür ederim geldiğiniz
için
Eee benim Türk Yıldızları maceram 2004
yılında başladı e 2004 yılında Türk
yıldızlarının o zaman Uçan lideri beni
çağırdı karşısına oturttu ve dedi ki Ayn
Biz seninle uçmak istiyoruz sen de
bizimle Uçmak İster misin Şimdi ben
aslında ilk bu soruyu
eaki Biz kavramını tam olarak
anlayamamıştım şöyle zannetmiştim Hani
vardır ya böyle çoğul konuşan kişiler
mutlaka karşılaşmış sınız Sizler de işte
biz bu yollardan tek başımıza geçtik
İşte biz sevdik mi ölümüne severiz gibi
ben de öyle bir cümle gibi algılamış tım
Ama öyle olmadığını Türk yıldızlarına
katılıp da ilk uçuşumu Yapmaya
Başladığım zaman anladım Bu öyle bir şey
değildi kol uçuşu yani Birden fazla Eee
uçakla yapılan Eee uçuş Aslında Eee
Aşina olduğum bir şeydi Çünkü bu Pilotaj
eğitiminin temelinde de bu vardır yani e
hava kuvvetlerindeki görevlere tek
başına gitmezsiniz birden fazla uçakla
gidersiniz ki birbirinizi destekleyin
Eee kollayın açıklarını Kapatın diye Eee
Aynı zamanda da yakın kol uçuşu yani
beraber yapılan uçuş da çok sık
yaptığımız bir şeydi Ben de E bu işlere
Aşina olduğumu Hatta pek de fena
olmadığımı düşünüyordum ama öyle
olmadığını ilk eğitim uçuşum da çok iyi
anladım Çünkü burası başka bir seviyey
hatta uçuştan döndüğümüzde Eee ya
meydanın üzerine gelip gelmediğimiz bile
anlamadım inişim falan da olmadı çok da
büyük hayal kırıklığı yaşadım
yapamayacak mıyım acaba diye
düşünmüştüm Çünkü Eee kol uçuşu tek
başına uçmaya
benzemez kolda uçarken Özellikle de
böyle seiz uçak bir arada binlerce
seyircinin önünde yerden sadece
metrelerce yukarıda bir şeyleri yapmak
bir arada yapmak kolay bir iş değildir o
yüzden sizin tek başınıza çok
kabiliyetli olmı Çok yetenekli olmanız
bir anlam ifade etmez herkesin o
seviyede olması gerekir kolda uçarken ne
kadar iyi uçtum diyemezsiniz ne kadar
iyi uçtuk dersiniz Çünkü bir kişinin
yapacağı bir hata bir kişinin yapacağı
bir uyumsuzluk bütün Ahengi bütün
görüntüyü bütün koreografiyi bozacaktır
o yüzden de aslında Sizler de Türk
yıldızlarını hep beraber manevralar
yaparken seyrettiğiniz alkışladığını
eee özendiğiniz gurur duyduğunuz Aslında
kişiler değildir tek bir isimdir tek bir
isim Türk Yıldızları işte birlik
beraberlik buna yol açar birlik
beraberlik
ayrıştırmak de kişiler değil toplum
yükselir Aslında ben Türk yıldızlarında
10 senenin 6 senesini solo olarak uçtum
yani o biraz önceki videoda da
seyrettiniz bütün o kesişimler alçak
uçuşlar terste
uçmaları hani böyle seyrederken Kim bu
çılgın dedikleri kişi bendim Ve o yüzden
de en çok bu soruya maruz kalan kişi de
ben oldum toplu hareketler mi zor yoksa
sol hareketler mi Ben bu soruya hep bir
soruyla karşılık verdim Onu da şimdi
size de sormak istiyorum ben olmak mı
zordur Biz olmak
mı İşte zaten O sorunun da cevabı Bu
soruda gizli Biz olmak zordur bana
sorarsanız da bir pilot Türk
yıldızlarında uçmaya ne zaman hazır olur
İşte biz olmayı öğrendiği zaman hazır
olur bu çok önemli
Eee Tabii belki sizler de Eee işte
firmalarını Okulunuzda böyle böyle
süpersonik bir ekip kurmak
isteyebilirsiniz Hani bizi başka bir
yerlere taşısın başka bir seviyeye
çıkalım gibi böyle bir düşünceniz Varsa
da benim size en büyük tavsiyem doğru
kişileri seçmektir bu doğru kişiler de
mutlaka tutkulu insanlardan olmalıdır
Çünkü Tutku ile işini L Tutku ile işine
koşanlar Tutku ile işine sarılanlar fark
yaratır Çünkü çünkü Tutku ile sevenler
fedakarlık yapmaya hazırdır ve bu işte
böyle işler de fedakarlık yapmadan olmaz
fedakarlıktan kastım da böyle basit bir
şey olarak düşünmeyin Kendinizden
ailenizden
sevdiğinizden Arkadaşlarınızdan
vücudunuzdan sağlığınızdan çok yıpratıcı
bir
iştir Kalb izden ruhunuzdan fedakarlık
yapmayı gerektirir
fedakarlıkla beraber başarı da gelir
başarı sizin özgüveninizi yükseltir
özgüvende tutkunuzu kamçılar O yüzden
bizlere maviye tutkulu gençler
lazım tabii şimdi
Eee bunun da getirdiği başka bir şey
daha var bu kadar tutkulu bir ekibi bir
araya getirdiniz ve büyük başarılara
imza attınız Bu da Tabii Aslında
ekibinizin içerisinde egoların da
yükselmesine olacak yani
eee Düşünsenize Hani herkes size en iyi
Sizsiniz diyor o pozisyonun Tek adamı
Sizsiniz bu ister istemez sizde de ya
ben mi acaba sorusunu mutlaka ortaya
çıkartır
İşte bu tutkulu ekipteki bu egoları
törpüleyen taşlara yaptığı gibi o
keskinlikleri sivrilik yi alıp
dalgalarla beraber bir uyum içerisinde
hareket etmelerini sağlayacak kişi
liderdir Tabii
Eee şunu da söylemek istiyorum İsminizin
yanında bir numara veya Lider yazıyor
olması sizi ne bir numara ne de lider
yapar bunu başaracak olan kişinin
kendisidir
Tabii
Eee bu liderle ilgili veya işte bir
liderde olması gereken özellikler nedir
falan gibi başka bir konuşma konusu
yapabiliriz Ama ben gene de böyle çok
olması gereken birkaç özelliği
vurgulamak istiyorum bunlardan bir
tanesi
özgüvendir Özgüven de yeterlilikten
gelir Özgüven yeterlilikten gelir ne
demek Özgüven yeterlilikten gelir Ben
size bir örnek daha açıklamak istiyorum
Bu gördüğünüz Türk yıldızlarının sekiz
uçaklık formasyonu işte yanlarında
numaraları da yazıyor Ben Türk
yıldızlarına ilk katıldığımda 3 numara
olarak uçmaya başladım sonra 5 numara
pozisyonuna geçtim daha sonra 7 numara
uçtum solo Lider oldum sonra 6 numaraya
geçtim Sonra tekrar 7 Numara uçtum sonra
8 numara uçtum en son 1 numara uçtum Ben
1 numara pozisyona Geldiğimde orada
uçmaya hazır olduğumu biliyordum Eee o
özgüvene de sahiptim Ama bu sadece Eee
Benim özgüvenim de yeterli değil aynı
zamanda benimle beraber Uçan diğer bütün
arkadaşlarım da güvenini kazanmıştım
Çünkü ben bütün bu pozisyonlarda
uçmuştur Eee elimden gelenin en iyisini
yapmaya çalışmıştım pek çok yeni hareket
eklemiştim pek çok yeni
Eee kareografi Dizayn etmiştim yani
Kimin ne yapacağını ne kadar yapacağını
gayet iyi biliyordum ve ekibim de bu
sayesinde güveni de kazanmıştım şimdi
buradaki
Güven kelimesinin seviyesini size
anlatmak için bir örnek vermek istiyorum
Eee Amerikan Hava Kuvvetleri gösteri
ekibi thunderbirds bu işle ilgilenenler
belki duymuştur bunlar bir eğitim
uçuşuna çıkıyorlar 4 uçak 1 2 3 4 numara
Lider uçarken yanlış bir hesaplama da
yapıyor aslında tam böyle burun aşağı
pozisyonda yere Vuracaklar anlıyor
Telsizden basıp söylüyor diyor ki sorry
guys diyor yani özür dilerim Beyler
diyor karşı taraftan gelen tepki şu two
3 F diyorlar ve 2 3 4 4 uçak birden yere
vuruyorlar buradaki Güven böyle bir
Güven Yani oradaki ekibin canını emanet
ettiği kişi olabilmek o güveni kazanmak
kolay bir şey değil Tabii bir de bir
karizma meselesi var hani böyle çok
konuşulan eden karizma Lider
birleştirilen bir şey bana sorarsanız
karizma dediğiniz şey içinizdeki tutkuyu
aktarabilme gücüdür
Yani siz karşınızdakine tutkunuzu ne
kadar aktarabiliyor olan içinizdeki o
ateşi karşı tarafa nasıl ne kadar
geçirebiliyor o derece Karizmatiksin iir
Belki de işte o yüzden bir yanardağ
gördüğünüzde etkilendiğiniz ona hayran
kaldığınız anda o işte ateşlerin çıktı
andır belki de o yüzden
Eee bu konuyu da belirtmek istedim diğer
bir konu da bu liderle ilgili
E biraz da yüce gönüllü olabilmelidir
Yani belki en büyük başarının sebebi o
olsa da bir başarı Karşısında bir adım
geriye çekilip ekip arkadaşlarını ön
plana çıkartıp Bu benim başarım değil
onların başarısı
diyebilmeli aynı zamanda tam tersi
olduğunda bir başarısızlık olduğunda da
bir adım öne çıkıp Bu benim
başarısızlığı deyip o başarısızlığı da
kabul edebilmelidir
Gerçi bunu yaptığı zaman o bir adım
gerideki Arkadaşların hepsi de onunla
beraber bir adım öne çıkıp Hayır bu
bizim başarısızlığınız hepimizin
diyeceklerdir zaten bu olduğu zaman siz
bu ruhu yakalayabilen düştüğünüz yerden
kalkmanız ve yükselmen ve tekrar aynı
seviye Hatta üstüne gelmeniz çok daha
kolay
olacaktır Şimdi size bir hikaye
anlatacağım bu
gerçek 13
Mart
2000 12 günü biz bir eğitim uçuşu için
briefing yaptık 5 uçak brifingde Şunları
da konuştuk
e bizden bir hafta önce İngiliz Red bir
uçak kaybetmişti gösteri bit her şey
bitmiş en sonunda inişe gelirken şunu
söylediğimi hatırlıyorum uçuş Park
yerine gelip motor durdurunca biter
dediğimi işte uçuş tesis atlarımızı
giyerken Ümit 3 numaramız eğitimini
bitirmişti İlk ssdi o gün eğitiminden
sonra Eee o yüzden böyle göğsümüze
taktığımız isimlikleri peçleri eksikti
ben kendi isimliği çıkartıp ona
takmıştım böyle boyacı gibi uçuşa
gidilmez diye Biz o gün beş uçak kalktık
böyle soğuk bir gün kapalı bir hava
eee
bitti uçuşumuz meydanın üzerinde
uçuyoruz Konya meydanının e Türk
hızlarının son hareketi vardır açılım
hazır şimdi böle 5 uçak açılırlar bunun
Lider bu komutu verdi açılım hazır şimdi
kestik Şimdi biz de tam iniş anayız Ben
arka kokpitte oturuyorum önümde 7 Numara
Eğitim alan bir arkadaş vardı Ben
öğretmen pilotu olarak oturuyorum
tahsilden şöyle bir ses geldi Ümit çok
alçak Ümit atla atla diye ben kafamı
çevirdiğimde Alev topunu
gördüm şimdi bu öyle bir an ki siz Bu
gördüğünüz şeyin gerçek olduğuna
inanamıyordu oldu ama bunu Kabullenmek
istemiyor insan
Eee ne oldu ben tahsile basıp gördüm Her
şeyi gördüm ama gene de sordum kuleye
atlama var mı diye cevap gelmedi
tabii biz toplandık gene bir şekilde
kendimize geldik
indik indikten sonra geriye dönüyor gene
Türk yıldızlarının düzenini
bozmadan kule dedi ki
Telsizden Türk Yıldızları aramızda
olmayan Kim
dedi Şimdi bu soruya cevap vermenin
yükünü ağırlığını Ben şimdi burada size
anlatacak kelime bulamıyorum ama
sizlerin bunu kalbinizde hissettiğinden
eminim geri geldik Park yerinde uçakta
indik
sarıldık
ağladık sonra ben dedim ki annelerimizi
arayalım herkes annesini aradı Çünkü
Eee ismi kimse bilmiyor o yüzden
Herkesin annesi de yüreğine bir ateş
düşecekti
mutlaka ertesi gün ayın 14'ünde kırmızı
uçuş tulumlar mızı giydik Ümit'in
cenazesini omzumuzda taşıdık Samsun
çarşambaya gittik başında nöbet tuttuk
defnettik ayın
15'inde Konya'da o enkazın üstünde
tekrar prova
uçtuk ayın 16'sında
18 Mart gösterisi için Bandırma
Meydanı'na intikal
ettik bu fotoğraf
da 18
Mart
2012'den Biz bir sene boyunca bu
fotoğrafta gördüğünüz gibi bir uçağın
yerini boş bakarak uçtuk Bir sene
boyunca ve bir sene boyunca Telsizden
hiçbir zaman 3
demedik
bu anlattığım
hikaye hikaye de değil aslında gerçek
Biraz önce anlattığım her şeyin Belki de
vücut bulmuş haliydi şu an isimler
değişti şu an orada başkaları uçuyor ama
hala her 19 Mayıs'ta Samsun'a
gittiklerinde ümid'i ziyaret etmeyi
unutmuyorlar Hatta ve hatta fırsat
bulurlarsa üzerinden
bir geçiş de
yapıyorlar O
yüzden Türk
yıldızlarını ne kadar
alkışlasın
yıllardır korkmadan yılmadan
cesaretle bize dostluğun arkadaşlığın
Biz olmanın ne kadar yoğun ne kadar Ulvi
ne kadar kucaklayıcı
bir duygu olduğunu gökyüzünde
gösterdikleri için o yüzden her zaman
diyorum Tekrar söylüyorum sizlerin
huzurunda Türk yıldızlarında uçmak öyle
sadece bir bilek değil kocaman da bir
yürek ister Eee o yüzden beni
dinlediğiniz için ve alkışlarınızla
onları onurlandırdınız için çok teşekkür
ederim Çok sağ
olun